- Yo, what's up, man? I gotta get these little legs home.
- Looks like you wandered into SHUTDOWN CORNER.
- Oh hell ya, it’s the Receiver Corps!
♪♪♪ - RECEIVER CORPS! You best believe-a... ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ It’s a job for a diva! ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ RECEIVER CORPS! ♪♪♪
- [Together:] GO, WIDEOUT, GO!
- Ayo, what's this bear's name?
- The CORNAS have captured our struggling QBs.
We need our top receiver to bail them out again.
- OK, fine.
I'll go.
- [Together, laughing]
- For real, though. I can’t do it cuz I’m the only one who will receive
Aaron’s nightly ramblings.
- Hey, Davante, tonight we’re gonna prove how the CIA killed JFK.
- I should go. DK can tackle anything.
- BOOO!
- That was one time, dude
- We play offense!
- Nuk?
- Can't. Got a thing.
- He's so cool.
- I got a thing too because we’re the same.
- Mike?
- I refuse to help. But only because my feelings are hurt.
- This may be a job for our new weapon.
- Let’s just say it’s gonna be...booming.
- [Together:] IT'S A LITERAL TICKING TIME BOMB!
- [Together:] AHHH!!!!
- Set me free.
- LOOK, WE'LL NEVER TRULY BE KIDNAPPED
UNLESS WE’RE KIDS AT HEART—
- Let.
- Jones.
- Run.
- Trust.
- Us.
- [Daniel Jones:] I’M ALMOST FREE!
OH, OW, OW, O—
[Loud crash]
- Yo, I’m Robby Anderson, and this is Sir Purr.
Ya, we call him that.
I didn’t know, but Sir Purr is a panther, not a bear.
Now he’s my best friend. And we go on adventures together.
We solve crimes and s--t.
It's dope as f--k
And now you know.
- AND KNOWING IS HALF THE BATTLE.